what who's that cute boy
is this your birthday party and i wanna
probably i wanna can i come home to your
birthday party please
nicki minaj's baby boy is one year old
yes the rapper's son nicknamed papa bear
recently turned one and had a kung fu
themed birthday bash and nikki who
shares her baby boy with her hubby
kenneth petty shared several moments
from the celebration on instagram
tuesday i'm very excited about that we
are talking sparklers on a giant cake a
table full of panda themed desserts a
massive bounce house green and blue
dragon balloon garland and a decorative
wall that nikki papa bear kenneth and
all their friends and family stood in
front of and took lots and lots of pics
i want to be great at anything i do the
grammy winner also paid tribute to her
little one on his milestone b day with
this instapost writing quote on
september 30th you turned one mama is so
proud of you papa bear you're the best
boy in the whole wide world i don't know
what i did to deserve you but god bless
you son mommy and daddy will never stop
loving you yes absolutely
and i'll wear that title proudly too and
if that didn't have you feeling all the
feels just wait because nikki also
shared some throwback clips and pics of
her son over the past year how about
[ __ ] morning
how about what you're doing
what to do
the super bass rapper later admitted
that they forgot to sing to the birthday
boy and cut the cake while the guests
were still there but don't worry papa
got his b-day song in his pjs
you cut your first piece of cake pop-pop
look
that's it
as for nicki last month she opened up
about how motherhood has changed her
telling fans on twitter that having a
son gave her quote more patience and
understanding with everyone when another
fan asked if they plan to stay a family
of three or if they plan to grow their
family she responded simply grow
and even before the musician became a
mama she told et she was
you know working hard on making that
dream a
reality talk about the family like how
hard are we practicing right now not to
put you on the spot
you're practicing practice all the time
like i'm just you know with the time
tonight um okay but the thing is
okay the truth is
at first i was like i want to know when
and now i want it now and then
and then i started thinking
if i if i want it right right now or if
i want to wait like another year because
i have a couple things that i have to do
the thing
possibly
possibly
[Music]